[Music]
welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Noelle valise she's a professor of
Spanish who studies interdisciplinary
approaches to modern Spanish culture
including religion literature and
celebrity she has received a number of
honors and awards including the Victoria
Urbano academic achievement prize in
2017 for her work in Hispanic Women's
and Gender Studies today we'll talk with
Professor Valles about her book Lorca
afterlife welcome professor Valles thank
you thank you so much I'm it's a
pleasure being here so I'm excited to
talk about your book let's begin with an
overview of that tell us about it well
it's a book that centers on Federico
Garcia Lorca one of the great poets and
playwrights of modern Spain and of the
world perhaps the most translated writer
in the Spanish language certainly as
much translated as Cervantes and Volquez
and what I Center on is Lord Pei as a
cultural icon so that's where the title
comes home from afterlife but of course
to talk about Lord afterlife you also
have to talk about him a little bit
before us who was he ah lorica Lorca was
one of these kind of unique figures that
Spain tends to produce like the great
painter Goya in the 19th century 18th
and 19th centuries and he he he was a
how can I say this I guess the easiest
way to say this is the first time I read
Lord I fell in love with his work it was
a really personal reaction to him and
and I think that's what the case for a
lot of people who first run across Laura
and I ran across him when I was a
college student like the way many people
do especially in this country I guess a
way to say to you who was
workers maybe just to tell you a few
recite a few lines from his poetry sure
for example there's a wonderful poem
that almost everybody reads it's called
rider song and some of the last lines if
I can remember them and if not we'll go
we'll skip to the next segment the lines
are as follows I can work them it's
better and this thing you gotta Cordova
Cordova Lahaina Isola Oh the death
awaits me before I ever get to court a
lot Cordova distant and alone
those lines are very mysterious or the
lines from another poem that almost
everybody reads it's called The Ballad
of the moon romance a de la Luna Luna
and the last lines of that poem are aji
como can't assume aiya como can't
inaudible porous yellow Bilal una con el
nino me Romano oh how the night jar
sings how it sings in the trees through
the sky goes the moon with a child in
its hands it's not gorgeous yeah I
specially I'm Spanish yeah so I wanted
to at least it doesn't really matter if
you can understand the lines because
they have such a magic you know that the
Spanish with Lorca has these magical
qualities and one of the things are so
interesting about Laura K is you can you
look at these lines you say what do they
mean what do they mean and behind a lot
of this poetry not all of it but behind
a lot of it is death I often say when I
teach Lorca to my students I say I for
me death is the precondition for his
poetry you just really can't understand
it without that probable case for others
to why do you think that is that's a
hard question to answer perhaps in part
because the poet's voice is always in
one sense posthumous he leaves his work
he leaves this life and what does he
leave us that's what he leaves us with
it's it's a posthumous life I'm not the
first to say
this but it seems to me a very apt way
of understanding literature in general
but on a more personal level I think
Lorca was rather obsessed with with
death and of course people always
connect that with him because of the way
he died as well that is one of the
things that anyone who leads even a few
lines of Lorca and looks him up to oh my
god yes was murdered about that well he
was a very strong supporter of the
Second Republic which was a
democratically elected government and in
the summer of 1936 a civil war broke out
it started as a coup a military coup
against the legitimately elected
government and Lorca always went back in
July to get another his hometown in the
south of Spain and he was there and a
few days later the war broke out he hid
in the house of a friend of his because
he understood that they were they were
looking for him and they found him and
by August he was dead they shot him and
probably in large part because he was a
supporter of the Republic now we think
there were probably multiple motives and
one of the motives might have been as
well the fact that it was gay and that
is also one of the things I look at I
don't review all the history of his
death because that's been done huge
amount of times and and and quite well
Ian Gibson the great biographer that has
done this for example but what I wanted
to look at is well how was he imagined
the fact that he was he died in such an
extraordinary way
not very many poets are actually
assassins writing this way and certainly
very very few who were gay
so I thought well let's look and see how
he was imagined his in his dying moments
that was one of the things that I wanted
to look at because that is contributed
hugely to his iconic status okay and
let's talk about that how was he
imagined and also he died relatively
young I think 41 and my god actually I
think 38 Wow 1898 to 1936 yeah okay yeah
yeah well one of the most iconic poems
is by entering the my
Chavo and he imagines him marching
serenely through the streets accompanied
by his executioner's and facing death in
a kind of heroic fashion that is
obviously something he is imagined
because nobody who witnessed this has
ever really spoken in at all about how
he died so that is one of the ways that
he's been imagined in other ways it's
it's it's been as a martyr to the cause
of Republican Spain to the values of
democracy and you can still see these
this kind of imagining even today
because he's often connected with the
transition to democracy after the death
of the dictator Franco so that's one of
the things I looked at and there was a
huge amount of material I had to kind of
pare it down and just take a number of
examples obviously but the other thing I
wanted to do was I looked at four
different aspects of the way he might
have been imagined or thought of and
some of them actually he was imagining
this way even in life but mostly after
death and I looked at them as as
imaginary communities so the first one
was Lorca and the dead and I'm giving
you a couple of examples of how you can
see him that way
but it's also the literary dead you know
in the Dead Poets Society okay to take
the title from that wonderful movie
right from the 1980s and then another
thing that I look at is lorg and the
people and a third is Lorca and the
right the political right and the last
is Lorca and gays okay so let's talk
about each of those of course you did
touch him on the deathbed right what
about the people who are the people
that's though what that is a number one
question and I can't say that I could
definitively tell you who the people are
because it really depended on on which
group was talking about and laying claim
to the people during the Civil War and
afterward but what I can say is they
they saw Lorca as the people's poet the
left in particular and the Republicans
in particular saw him is the people's
poet and so and this was deeply
connected obviously to the
the Republic and it's fascinating to see
this because lorica was what you would
call a senorita now in Spanish that
seemed kind of difficult to translate
but it means that he came from a rather
comfortable background his father was a
wealthy landowner not high up socially
speaking but he certainly had a
comfortable life and lorica did not have
to work for work for him for a living
and in fact his father supported him
during most of his his life and his
career he only started earning money
toward the last few years with his plays
in particular having said that he knew
as a senorita he never worked harder I
mean he was you know he really was
dedicated to us this is a kind of a
class distinction and it is kind of
ironic you know that he would be seen
this way but on them the only other hand
is maybe it's not ironic because he also
identified very closely with the pop
what we would call the popular classes
and he had a great deal of sympathy
toward them and since he was not of that
class because he I think partly because
of in his his formative years he was
raised in the countryside and like
others from his background there was he
was closely in contact with with those
are the more humble classes the people
who were surrounded him were from these
classes and he imbibed like others
before him the popular culture of the
humbler classes man and he and it spoke
to him he felt some empathy yeah whereas
other people could probably you know I
don't say in Spain there's a tradition
here too because there's such a rich
popular tradition say the oral tradition
of poetry and there's not this heavy or
very clear-cut divide or antagonism
between say popular poetry that is the
oral tradition and and the written more
refined tradition of poets many of them
we are inspired by this popular
tradition not just the Lord of God right
so it's not surprising in that sense so
was Lorca very well-known during his
lifetime as a poet yes he was as a poet
and a playwright
he was famous he was a celebrity and
indeed when you look at somebody and his
I count iconic status you're really
looking at his celebrity and his fame
and he was bokes he was a celebrity and
he was a famous person and he continued
to be after his death he still is you
know we tend to think what celebrity is
pretty fleeting and it generally is Fame
we same can also be fleeting but it
tends to be a little more enduring in
comparison and fame in the in its
origins was something that people
associated more with accomplishments
with deeds with something virtuous
celebrity we tend not to to associate it
as much although a celebrity can
certainly have accomplishments but on
the other hand there are lots of
celebrities who are only famous for
being celebrities those who knows yes
especially the case today so I ended up
really also at the same time as I was
looking at this individual case of
lorica meditating about you know what
does it mean to be a celebrity what is a
celebrity and and what surrounds
celebrity what surrounds a celebrity so
those four groups that I was talking
about the dead the gays the right and
the people in part come out of the
celebrity status the fame of lorica Lord
who produces these communities which are
not always harmonious which reflect the
fractured history of Spain so what about
the gay is that section talk a little
bit about that how did they imagine him
this was one of the most fascinating
things for me certainly other scholars
have looked at Lorca and as gay or
looked at what they can perceive in his
poetry that has to do with him being gay
and there's some very fine work that's
been done in all the all these areas
certainly but one of the things that
surprised me
was how much I realized I didn't know
about the 1920s and 30s and what it
meant to be gay in Spain and so tell us
about yeah the clarinha the cachet is
that it was was terrible to be gay in
that period and certainly it was not
easy no one should ever think otherwise
and that's the case everywhere but on
the other hand this was actually the
period when you start to see some more
visibility it's it's still somewhat
timid let us say but you definitely see
more visibility in society and in
literature and the arts I would say that
that was one of the things that I found
to be really fascinating I discovered
another gay figure who's a contemporary
of Lorca one that who now is being
looked at far more often than before he
sort of fallen into neglect and I found
it very interesting to compare him who
his name is Alberto Ratana and he wrote
these rather racy stories and novels and
he's a dress designer and he wrote songs
so he a man of all trades so to speak
and he was often seen as publicly gay or
at least bisexual in comparison to Lord
Coe who was never out of the closet
which was more the case than not
foremost most gays in the Shariat but I
found that really interesting that you
could look at this and see that being
gay could mean different things
depending on the person the personality
the group's they they were in and so on
and so forth so then I started looking
at well he was barely referred to as
being gay during the period of his
lifetime there were a couple of insult
there were a few insulting references to
him in newspapers that did not
particularly care for Lorca and you
could see that a little bit afterward as
well but for the most part there was a
kind of screen or veil you know thrown
over his the fact of being homosexual
and so what what I discovered is that
you really have to wait a while before
after his death before people
started reflecting on that but when they
did it was really interesting and and I
think one of the most fascinating
aspects was to see how other gay writers
looked at him and can you give an
example of some of them yeah
Ginsberg in Ginsberg it's a brief but
it's but it's telling there's a
wonderful poem of his in howl his iconic
collection a supermarket in California I
think it's called where he he spots Walt
Whitman and Lorca in a grocery store
among the avocados and peaches and pears
and and at one point you know he talks
about Walt Whitman eyeing the grocery
boys and and he notices that Lorca's
down there as well although he doesn't
say that he's eyeing the grocery boy and
and toward the end of the poem he he
talks directly to Walt Whitman he says
what Whitman where are you going you
know this the store closes in an hour
what which way does your beard point so
it's a wonderful poem and it is a way
curiously I think of outing Lorca in a
peculiar way and a funny ironic way and
and poignant too because of the
connection with Walt Whitman and so I
look at that as a kind of a double
outing they go on an outing to a grocery
store but it's also another outing so in
writing the book how did you do the
research I mean there's so much as you
pointed out volumes of material so how
did you how did you go about picking
what you did to do the book oh that
there was a challenge and it's one of
the reasons why it took me several years
to do do this project you the research
and the writing and also because I'm
just very slow because there's heaps
written on fevicol Garcia Lorca it's
like writing on board okay so Cervantes
I certainly didn't read everything but I
read a huge amount I just felt that I
needed to make sure that I covered my
bases for one thing but also there was a
lot that was quite interesting but I
also found a lot of primary sources
and some of them that people had a lot
of them that people already use but I
wanted to look at it in a different way
you can oh you know you can always go
back to these sources and find other
ways of looking at them and so that was
very interesting as well
were there any personal letters that you
were able to read both him and other
people yeah well there's a solid body of
Correspondence and a lot of it has been
published fortunately so that was
something was readily available to me
and I certainly read his correspondence
and I read some correspondence that was
to him as well as the letters of he
wrote and I found for example online
there was a wonderful archive from a
poet friend of his named Luis Rosales
and that turned out to be quite
interesting and and it hardly had all
been touched with respect to lorica so
yeah I found some interesting stuff good
there's a bit of mystery actually
surrounding his death from from what I
had read in there so no one knows where
his remains are I write about that okay
it is quite interesting and you know
some people throw up their hands and say
do we need to talk about this one more
time you know especially in Spain they
can sort of feel frustrated and fed up
you know because it has been dealt with
so many times but we don't know where he
is and there have been a number of
excavations and each one has come up
empty and so it is one of the you know
the enduring mysteries about him
sometimes it overshadows a bit his work
which is obviously the most important
thing but at the same time my view is if
this is clearly important to people so
we should look at it at least one more
time right so what do you conclude in
the book well I look at I try to look
and see what his celebrity ultimately
produced obviously its work as well I'm
not trying to say it's just a celebrity
but it seems to me that unless you're
someone with an enduring impact like
Lorca you're not going to be able to
understand how those four groups that I
mentioned had such a had such a an
impact I
his his celebrity his fame had such an
impact on these four groups I think
would be better said so that in essence
what we're talking about is that lorica
has an individual and a communal
identity and that celebrity itself is
actually quite crowded literally and
virtually in the sense that one of the
things that surrounds celebrity and fame
are crowds and I talk about that as well
they don't have to be real they can be
virtual but it's crowds you know and
these communities are in some sense also
different types of crowds and so I I
ended the book with a small PostScript
in which I looked at a letter from a
fourteen-year-old Spanish school boy who
wrote a letter to Luis Rosales the
friend of vodka in 1989 asking him one
question he said how do you remember
Federico Garcia Lorca he didn't get an
answer because the sally's was sick and
he was really actually close to to his
end but he wrote to other people as well
who did answer him and I thought that
was fascinating because he was really
asking for an interview of sorts and it
was a fan letter was a fan letter
he was an admirer of vero Sally's and
lorica and I thought that was a perfect
example of what I was talking about and
the same guy the 14 year old schoolboy
when many many years later he became a
journalist and a writer and he wrote
about Lorca and he also participated in
organizing yet one more of these
excavations trying to find Lucas body
what a nice story yeah well thank you so
much for being here with us today and
sharing your work I really enjoyed it
thank you I enjoyed it tremendously
Marilyn for more information about
professor Valles and her research please
visit our website at macmillan report
yale.edu be sure to join us again for
another episode of the Macmillan report
made possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at you
you